struggling to break free from the same
old politics they represent a new
generation of Voters Callum Mark and
Sophie work with young people from lower
income families and of more pressing
concerns than the brexit protocol the
reality is paying your bills is harder
now than actually discussing the
protocol I don't really care about the
protocol anymore I'm more concerned
about the people in the community that
can't afford their oil bill they can't
you know afford their food prices have
went through the roof and I'm seeing it
through school and just in everyday life
like in school I'm paying nearly 10
pounds for a meal and that's just to
feed myself for one day
it's six months since Shin Fan's
historic Victory winning the most seats
at Stormont Michelle O'Neal on course to
become the first nationalist to hold the
office of first Minister but the dup
won't restore power sharing unless the
brexit Border in the Irish sea is
scrapped so Northern Ireland faces
another election much to the frustration
of these young voters young people want
to go on a holiday young people want to
be able to afford to get a house young
people want to be able to grow up and
get married young people on a society
that works
rather than what flags flying on the
Lamppost they say that isn't like the
main issue right now and whether you're
British or Irish if you can't afford
these things what's the use in in either
really
Northern Ireland has the lowest
disposable income in the UK and the
highest energy prices there's little
appetite for a rerun of the pole at a
cost of six and a half million pounds if
there's another election it will
illustrate two things the damage brexit
and the resulting protocol has done to
power sharing in Northern Ireland and
the widening Gulf between the people and
the politics because many voters are
more concerned about how they hit the
house and put food on the table than
they are about where Northern Ireland's
political future lies
if there's no power and the corridors at
Stormont there's no hope for people when
they need it most and that could signal
the end of Good Friday agreement
politics David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast